big space exploration news astronomers
have found at least seven earth-sized
planets orbiting the same star not
exactly nearby 40 light-years away
discoveries this far outside of our
solar system can be rare because planets
don't always have the winning
combination of being a similar size to
earth and also having relatively
habitable climate and that could maybe
allow for water on the surface which
could maybe potentially support life and
this is the first time that this number
of planets were all found around one
star this is an ultra-cool dwarf star
called trappist one not to be confused
with trappist style beers this is this
is the trappist one star and estimates
of the mass of some of these planets
suggests that their rocky planets so
Jupiter is a gas planet these are not
jupiter-like planets these are rocky
planets three of the seven planets are
in what's considered the habitable zone
of the star these are trappist 1 e f and
g and some of them might even have
oceans on the surface trappist 1 f in
particular is considered the best
candidate for maybe supporting life it's
cooler than earth could be suitable with
the right atmosphere and a Trappist one
was actually discovered back in May and
now research has found additional planet
let's put up this picture for people who
are watching with us you can see here
many of these planets closer to their
stars then is Earth a lot of these
planets have very very short years so
here on earth we have an orbital orbital
period which I i like to call
colloquially one year of 365 just over
365 days some of these planets have
orbital periods of one two four six nine
twelve and roughly twenty days imagine
that Pat a sixth day year on one of
these planets that would certainly on
paper make it seem like people are
living a really long time obviously an
actual time it wouldn't change anything
I would be sold by now it's like those
people who are born on februari 29th so
even though it's right there quite older
than they seem they may only be four or
five years old yes very very a pointless
way of manipulating time now so the we
are talking about planets that are 40
light-years away this is very far could
take between 50,000 and millions of
years to travel that distance depending
on which technology you have in mind
people often get discouraged when we
make an announcement like this and then
it's like yeah we'll never get there
because it's 40 light-years away big
announcements can sometimes sound small
just remember the cumulative effect of
all of these discoveries we've got to be
getting closer to something big on space
travel don't you think well I think even
just regardless of the fact that we can
get there or not it would just be
fascinating to find if they have water
there perhaps even liquid water yeah and
then if that planet can support life
because to find life on other planets I
mean that's a big discovery whether you
can get there or not indeed